spooky scary maps Fuji scary man so I'm
with Bob Jack you a baby haha I just
joined it have done this one before is
this new look familiar
all right all these cars have cones in
front of them it's neat
all right let's see one of them probably
doesn't and you just pulled a fast one
on us
spooky scary spooky this good spoop when
you when you get in here
oh alright wait I get in the front door
just look out for the creepiest thing
you could ever see what one of these
things can you actually become oh my god
it's a picture of mark no wait wait I
found the scariest is it a scary thing
off mark did we have the same idea
that's a chair can I try my spooky bit
okay okay okay I have a chair I would
chair
[Applause]
mark lesson learned chairs with wheels
aren't scary
[Music]
alright that's just a lazy chair that's
what that is no I'm scared of a lazy
chair because what do you still them to
death squeak squeak mark you know what
else is scarier than a chair with wheels
child a wheel without a chair it was a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
rotting milk can't hurt whiny emotional
metal is that boys smokes just to piss
off my mom but what a way to go though
right
no oh oh god that actually but I offer
no sustenance I just saw errormsgs
peeking through the corner wait
disclosure you're never gonna find me
wait can you actually try and not just
pick the first thing you find yeah Wade
can you please go back to the drawing
board and and really give me ask
yourself a better throw yourself a
better late Wade's orgasm sound are you
from an 80s oh the sex is so good
Oh baby I don't know this is errormsgs
here's the stairs are you the basement
it's their basement - this [ __ ] no I'm
on the upstairs there yeah that's
terrifying it's like a way to get to the
basement but I don't know it's locked
yeah you guys wanted me to try I tried
and I'm stuck well good job so what you
say when you do it wow this is a fish
that's not what I thought it was I don't
know I saw it from sort of a certain
angle that made it look sort of dickly
logan paul i hear the gunshots oh i see
an open door up there yeah I see you Bob
damn where were you guys are just doing
the same room I've been in man Oh
fact oh hey Betty Oh see you buddy
Eddie where are you are you trying to be
spoopy Wade no I see them on the balcony
I'm staying up there looking my
direction but they can't see me because
I'm looking at them through who's they
I'm in a completely different spot whoa
guys I could do a magic trick wait guys
do I even flickering guys guys
everyone needs to come here everyone
needs to come to them
well there you are there's a light
flickering on the in here somewhere it's
like a alright wait but wait wait wait
wait everyone look at me magic trick I'm
watching bye Nana Nana Nana Nana nanana
nanana Nana
over here on the left in there no in
there yeah that was yeah you're safe
thank you I found where I belong is it
into trash no it's cooler than that so
you guys can all suck a huge dick wait
you know this place or any of these
different I heard a door door okay you
guys actually trying this round no I'm
not really trying but I'm somewhere war
does it I found my favorite room and I'm
not leaving okay oh wait you found your
own padded room too yeah neat it's fun
right yeah I could be an airplane
they're fun oh hey wait wait this is my
room this is my room this is my room I
gotta give you your shot no no no no no
no but I didn't ask for that
come on for that put your hands on the
sink bend over I'll make it quick
about to do to me just give you a shot I
promise that's it but it's got to go in
the back of your thigh it sounds like
you're gonna do BUTT STUFF to me no I
always think that but it's just a shot
mark help no no no how can I possibly
help you ha ha I got you to leave my
room good luck getting in now no nope
nope nope no jack help he's gonna put
his peepee in my butt no who has my keys
I drove here my car this is my car it's
not that one no my car would accept me
for who I am don't do stuff to me your
traffic cone your traffic he said just
love me supposed to leave me I'll hit
you with this mattress I swear to dog
alright okay sir have you calmed down no
no I'm not ready yet
okay tell us when you're ready
hang on I'm not a traffic cone making
your traffic cone you're a traffic cone
ten seconds all right I'm ready
yeah you got the same ID as me wait yeah
ah there's your shot that's a good show
what's my peepee yeah what it's all I
gots preventing you from shooting me
that whole time it was so good they
couldn't shoot you sorry I know I'm so
much funnier than everyone else here
it's not my fault it's a burden well at
least you know now you can work on
improving yourself no throbbing myself
[Laughter]
mark like laying in bed with his iPad
watching like Rick and Morty so they can
just be like there's even dead people's
clothes in that room I'm into that I
told you that were naked people here
somewhere I mean they're clearly not
here when they're dead and oh yeah they
just left without their clothes I'm
gonna die I'm going out naked so yeah
we're gonna get naked and leave well
just like make this painting a little
bit creepier everyone but that person
did that person I just made this
painting or a creepy gotcha dude wait I
was looking for you can I see can I see
something real quick yeah now let me
just squat over you yeah and just
[Laughter]
Bob did the bottle shatters it's
little-known fact take ash I took a
Magnum dump on Wade
I thought you were easing him into your
ass and it broke on the injury I was
inserting weight in god damn where are
you guys I'm completely away from
everybody I'm ah yes somebody came into
my room and just left at me are you how
much time is left he goes looking
upstairs or downstairs I'm right here
yeah I think he was talking about me
being an idiot in this room yeah no he
just called me an ass look grandpa or is
that a child in the middle that you
didn't shoot there
it's a sad child why we're just making
it you are intense we know we know what
you are we know wait a minute you were
not in there here why what was he he was
a book set he was a set of books
Oh rose beard I didn't think you could
be that clever give away I've got a
winning Stratos time guys don't even
worry about it jump in the air if you're
out here I believe their lack of jumping
can I get a redo if you had walked
inside after looking over here that
would have been so funny
come on jump no I didn't jump cuz you
were looking right at me
you were like looking this way would you
said that and I was like oh [ __ ] why
were you here why are you not trying
because I'm blue I'm blue
look I blend in I it's perfect there is
right right
just give me like give me like a
five-second into the headstart and then
wait till three minutes will give you 30
seconds oh I don't need that much time
I'm awesome at this game I'm the best at
this game I don't know if you've seen my
work but pretty far well that case we're
coming to now yeah okay
come at me bro aha [ __ ] come at me
bro
be like the best at this game he come
right inside the door come at me
[ __ ]
you if you're not careful you could come
on me that's something that people have
to do sometimes seamen no no no come on
me not I'm not come I'm me market
shockingly silent just casually doing
something that's really try hard I feel
like that's pretty trihard what I'm
doing my scenario where I am pretty sure
wherever that may or may not be if I'm
even Hugh piece of [ __ ] yeah we're at a
table I'm something that people come on
with regular frequency oh that's true
Wow we were both we were both sort of
come things yes yeah we were come
magnets is what Bob was saying Bob and I
are both couch you know are you you know
you're not too far off are you this
person that's bloody on the toilet no no
no I mean you're not wrong but that's
not what he is yeah okay it's that whole
square rectangle situation it's like
everyone is not that that what for I'm
on the first floor that you will search
well not no it's not no one is even
close to him I'll say that why don't you
guys take a nap like hilarious why don't
you come on me
even are you guys what are you doing why
no idea were there
take it off come on if you're a mattress
or a bed frame or flour there's a dead
guy in my room he's really dead Oh like
the dentist there's a broken mattress
here hey buddy it's weird that you could
see the courtyard I don't have a good
time and there's a dead guy here like
the dentist you want are you
doors open just run around on the first
floor but be quick about it no no take
your time you're good you're good it's
not that interesting in here this is a
very dead guy this is a very bedless
mattress uh-huh
so you guys here for the special or what
are you guys here for uh
now what are you gonna come on yeah what
are you gonna do yeah you got nothing
jack was the Savior I've just I just I
just feel like I just got to say that
mm-hmm
jack is your own personal Jesus Christ
wait
I appreciate drink your blood and stuff
no well no that's that is actually kind
of part of the deal jack so it's not
really negotiable yeah my body as well
just a little bit at a time but yeah I
mean that's sort of the deal I mean
everyone's doing it so it's not really
that big of a deal yeah it's it's fine
right I mean you it's like him and his
family too so it kind of extends out and
like regenerate it you make more blood
turn your blood into my meal what the
[ __ ] funny thing is those mattresses are
like that when you go in they're all
broken oh yeah
there was no mattress on that bed I was
like he's never fine
I found a grenade Bay so I do have a
grenade what good things happen to those
who try pretty sick burn it's Bob cuz
beyond that Bob didn't try yeah I feel
like I just went on the whole thing
about how I did try though yeah I
couldn't see him inside I gave up mmm
that's what I'm saying yeah well you can
watch me anytime you want Jake aren't
you busy ghosting these guys yeah are
you good to watch wait is that what
we're talking about here you're oh I'm
very good to watch you're a watch like I
make you want to come on things you can
watch things on me to make you uh it's
it like a voyeuristic thing should I
watch you like through some blinds or is
it more like if you want I mean honestly
you could just prop me up and have them
I know what you are but I'm not gonna
say it you know out loud yeah what you
think I don't know what he are no no I'm
pretty sure pretty sure we all know what
he is but I'm just not where you'd
expect me to be I guess hurried away
right now
I I really am yeah you uh you find
anything there mark no no no Rumblers
downside I just don't know I mean I
wouldn't go any further to the other
side of the building for sure yeah
better than you didn't more on this side
are we on the correct floor the second
floor that wouldn't be right
doubtful so you're unlike the stairwell
in the basement no no not down it's so
well I would say I'm a little bit but
I'm not down the basement stairs he's
got about one horsepower right now yeah
I'm really low power doesn't make any
sense
Oh someone's close closer yeah someone's
miracle Pole owing their way over here
maybe lights not know oh I think you Bob
- Bob hey there it's not yeah warmer
yeah started building you [ __ ] liar
who's outside I was on the other side
right now yeah yeah I'm only coming in
if you're MLG
I'm pretty much on fire you don't walk
to see if there's a blue person here I'm
not outside okay calm down
no he wouldn't that be pretty meta
though if I just did that and dropped it
right in front of you again and was just
like uh and you didn't see it car step
out you see that little privacy if you
close the door on your way out
didn't expect company this early so you
know if you just come on what are you
talking about I've just dinner's not
ready yet wait till the bell rings come
on rapscallion kids alright so you guys
still out here there's no hints yeah I
don't to give you a hint
my comeback are you still still here
hear that here's a hint that won't help
you there's a light bulb in my room mark
run like you mean it
have you seen any of us yet uh he's fine
not for a good while not for a little
while mark come on in I don't know man I
don't know man I don't know what to do
every time I try to come back it's
bright you know is fight cuz you guys
see a fish I'm just gonna I've been a
big error message like the whole I'm
still a tipos really mm-hmm
yeah it's amazing actually was almost
like you were in the basement that that
was not in the basement yeah I see where
it was the whole time Jack Jack I'm
behind you I'm over here you know I see
where I was the whole time while you
guys were running around
idiots oh well I'm not gonna show you
the spot that made you look like a [ __ ]
same spot that I died in but the
opposite side time was up he couldn't
take us
yeah wait caught on to my scheme I was
just trying to delay it no Jack it was
the same exact spot one of us [ __ ]
[Music]